[Music]
i think my ideal time to be
in the world is at dusk in the
summertime around 7 30 between 7 30 and
8 30. twilight time it's when fireflies
come out and the air is just perfect and
there's something about it especially in
the summer time when you're kids and
you're just finishing up playing and
it'll always be my favorite time we were
talking about how people who grew up uh
in other parts of the world and other
parts of the country even didn't get to
experience fireflies and and the wonder
when you see a kid see fireflies they
just light up so now you're bragging
about how lucky you are to live where
you live and that not everyone gets to
have fun i know well they have probably
have other cool things like the west
coast they have um coyotes that's pretty
cool that's pretty cool what else they
have um they have condors we don't have
condors we have vultures whenever i see
a vulture i think ah you know probably
because the way they're depicted in you
know children's books and stuff and
they're always like bad they're never
good vultures are never good in
in kids books and stuff also here's
another east coast phrase that's neither
here nor there
that's east coast no no
oh and that's true okay it just applies
to what i'm it applies to this whole
opening i guess that's right life could
be a dream
life could be a dream
you're listening to life is short i am
your uh neither here nor their host
justin long
sweetheart
with me is always in his new studio i'm
i'm in
christian's new house uh and he's got a
little studio that we've trans
transferred over here i would say it's
our studio our studio in your house it's
really cool um
does it sound different listeners
um yeah fireflies are it might sound
better
it might yeah we'll see listeners uh
fireflies are cool because they i think
it's only is it only the females that
are only the males that light up i don't
know i don't think that's why they're
cool that's a very massage that's a very
insect misogyny
thing to say canceled um in the bug
world i'm cancer but but uh it's also
interesting that around that time my
favorite time uh those great bugs the
fireflies come up but also mosquitoes so
you have to take take the good with the
pad oh my god there are so many
mosquitoes in this neighborhood oh yeah
i heard that you had a big i heard that
you m according to our mother that you
ran outside she was really worried she
loves finding things to worry about and
she said uh
go go christian i'm so worried he runs
outside and his poor little legs i don't
know if she said pour the legs
they're just covered
the whole leg is covered in mosquitoes i
mean i gotta say that wasn't that's not
really an exaggeration it wasn't an
exaggeration it was how why were they so
bad uh apparently and i didn't know this
when i bought this house but apparently
they're like notoriously bad in this
area oh like the worst in the state well
because you have water you're near it's
like it's the perfect storm it's like
near the water marshes very low lying
it's it's like everything that could
make mosquitoes
so i got this woman to come out and
spray this organic spray
this mosquito spray
around the perimeter of the yard
and
it completely solved the problem really
i haven't seen or felt a mosquito in a
couple weeks i noticed you no longer
have hair on your legs
and huge splotchy welts all over my body
yeah i haven't seen one though well good
well you take the good with the bad yeah
it really is like experiencing summer
i'm talking about those great summer
nights with fireflies summer days
without mosquitoes makes the day so much
better where do you draw the line
because i sometimes i have you ever met
people were such animal lovers my
girlfriend's mother is such a she feels
bad killing flies oh really yeah
i would have said you're an animal lover
too but you don't feel bad nothing flies
i kind of relish it i celebrate it if
anything which sounds kind of sadistic
but but i was thinking about what is the
cut off like between
you know compassion for animals and not
wanting to harm an animal like what what
size is it a size is it like a something
that you imagine to be intellectual
sentient i took an animal ethics course
when i was in college and it we tackled
all those types of issues and i think
really yeah it was really interesting
that's a huge factor it's
sentient and like the ability to feel
pain and how much pain which how do they
know which often corresponds to the size
of the brain right
so if you're talking about like a nat
or a fly even those brains are so small
that the pain level is going to be very
low
for one thing and also i think you
another thing you have to balance out is
what they're doing for the world and how
they're contributing to the ecosystem
so mosquitoes for example don't do
anything like they're just yeah
nuisances why are we talking about
mosquitoes and this time of day to dusk
some fireflies at a time you could call
twilight oh
okay okay okay are you getting a little
bit more of that yes yes because can i
say it yes because the
i'm answering i'm answering my own
rhetorical question right now don't do
that i think that's part of the show at
this point it's part of the charm
i wouldn't say charm uh because our
guest today was in
the
hit movie movies movies not just
franchises well i i stopped myself
because when i said hit i realized how
much of an understatement that was they
weren't just hit movies they were like
behemoths oh
what's bigger they were iconic like
generational yeah they defined they
defined the generation not our
generation no have you seen them let's
talk about that later
okay our guest today is the star one of
the stars co-stars of the twilight
franchise peter factionelli sorry i took
your no no please i wasn't getting there
no someone had to save
some steam uh he's peter peter uh
facinelli who we also know from
our generation loved a movie called can
hardly wait uh and he was one of the
stars of that he's been in many things
he's uh
we talk about fatherhood he's now in in
the role of fatherhood again yes um he's
been in he works all the time and now he
directs and yes he's behind the camera
now yes he is a jack of all trades a
peter of all trades
and uh we're gonna talk to him i can't
hardly wait to talk to him you knew you
were gonna say that yeah yeah i was
excited i ramped up it for that but
let's do it so let's do it and uh here
he is the uh star of the twilight
franchise and can't hardly wait and many
other things peter facianelli life could
be a dream sweetheart
[Music]
peter people think we're just beginning
now
in fact
for the last
for the last 15 minutes
yeah a solid 15 minutes um
you have an excuse you're not used to
doing you don't do this all the time no
i mean i have been on zooms since like
covid started so yeah i have zero excuse
because you think i would have gotten it
you know i know it's a little different
though because we're recording
i know but i have no excuse because i do
it every week i was on a zoom once and
uh there's a button where you could take
your picture off it's like hide your
profile or something and i thought that
meant that people couldn't see me but it
just meant that i couldn't see me
so i was like
so i was i was i was in a class actually
i was taking this class
and there's like 15 people in there in
the class that i don't even know
and uh and i and i and and i was at work
like like i had a white van you know
waiting for you downstairs to take me on
to set and i was like last five minutes
ten minutes and i started panicking
because i was like i'm gonna be late for
work so i said oh just i'll just
multitask and i'll take this into the
bathroom and i'll take a shower while
i'm listening no so like no
so i take the computer in i rip off my
shirt i'm like flexing in the mirror
like i gotta go to the gym all right and
then somebody goes you're somebody goes
have you been working out and i was like
oh my god can they see me and i freeze
like that can do anything right
i start panicking hitting all the
buttons i was like can you guys see
thank god i didn't take my pants off yet
because i was about to
do you think they knew that you
had pressed some button that you
couldn't see yourself and that was their
like nice way of alerting yeah i think
so i think yeah
yeah have you been working out that's
almost more embarrassing than just
taking your pants off in a way i'd be
less embarrassed if i just took my pants
off than if i were flexing
like admiring myself
like slapping my muscles like
am i getting sucked to go to the gym
today i'm thinking in my head and
somebody's like because i was like flexi
like this they're like working out and
i'm shirtless and the whole class is
staring at me and i don't see me so i'm
like and then what's worse is i was on
uh mute so then i'm like hitting all the
buttons trying to talk like
what was it what was the class for body
sculpting um i don't know i took so many
classes during kobe because i was so
bored
i got certified in hypnotherapy
what yeah
wow what what compelled you to do that
well you were hypnotized into doing it
yeah
now i've always been interested in
hypnotherapy because i think there's
something fascinating about the mind you
know because you can
listen
especially for what we do you know as
actors you're always putting yourself in
a state you know
um
but with hypnotherapy i mean look people
hypnotize themselves all the time you
know i mean you either psych yourself up
or you set yourself out right so if
you're like oh my god this is going to
go so bad i i i don't feel it then all
of a sudden you manifest that because
what you believe will come true
so like if you could
tap into your own mind and give yourself
suggestions to be like oh this is going
to be great it's going to be easy and
like manifesting yeah then all of a
sudden like
you reprogram your mind to believe that
because we are everything we believe
right whether you think you can or you
think you can't you're right was there a
specific incident was there something
that inspired you to want to delve
deeper into that well when i was younger
like coming out of
i think when i first started taking
acting classes i was just terrified like
i wasn't like
i wasn't like the ham that was like he'd
love to be on stage like you weren't
like a born performer no no i was like i
was so shy that like i couldn't even get
in the lunch line at school like like
paralyzingly shy like for the first
three years in high school i didn't even
get the lunch line because i was like
what if i drop something what if
somebody makes fun of me like what if
the whole
you know school just turns around and
starts laughing at me so like oh my god
that's so funny that's interesting to me
peter because i associate you so so
clearly with mike dexter from i mean i'm
sure a lot of people do that was such a
that was that was such a formative movie
for me that like it's it's interesting
to hear you say that that that would be
the opposite of what i i would have
imagined it was like the opposite of me
i mean i i took like three kids in high
school and kind of
formed that character around those three
kids that i that i had but
you must have been like just physically
i mean
you must have been a good looking
muscular kid in high school like a good
looking kid i don't know i mean i
i didn't see yourself that way it
doesn't matter what you
again it's like what you believe right
yeah yeah i was like a wallflower who
kind of was like friends with these kids
and friends with these i went to school
with 3 500 kids so i went to a big
school so like in queens right yeah in
queens so it was intimidating walking
down the hallway with you know that many
kids yeah there was so many clicks and
so many like groups and and so
you know when the bell rang i kind of
just got on the first bus home because i
didn't take like four buses to get home
wow wow and then i would i worked at a
grocery store so like
me too yeah awesome i actually that was
fun it was a fun time i know it isn't
funny to look back at those times i
sometimes do you ever fantasize about
doing that again i mean i sometimes
romanticize it maybe but um whenever
when i am in a grocery store at a
checkout i was a checkout guy at a um at
a grocery store i sometimes imagine how
i remember how i i
maybe sugarcoat the experience but i
have such fond memories of it it was fun
i was a stock boy so like uh yeah the
camaraderie of like you know we'd go
down the basement we'd have like yeah
we'd have food fights in the basement
they would get so mad there'd be like
food all over the place nobody knew who
did what but we'd like to be throwing
marshmallows at each other and eggs yeah
yeah i'd say we were just kids it was
like i was like 15. um but it was a good
time
why did you have to take so many buses
out of curiosity you know my school is
just like an hour and 20 minutes away i
didn't i don't know why i went to that
school like i didn't know it sounded
like oh this was a prestigious school to
go to
but i never really went to visit it
and nobody in my grammar school went to
that school
did your parents ever say do you ever
say to them like hey this is quite a
this is a haul why am i going with no
because it was just
you know it was known as a good school
yeah
i was just i had a good reputation i was
like oh i'll go to that i mean
technically like if you drive there it
was 25 minutes away right yes
if you had to take the bus i had to take
four buses so it was like an hour and a
half so it's just like when the bell
rang i just wanted to go home um but
yeah so i was super shy
and then when i started acting
i felt like oh this is great because
like nobody could see me they just see
this character that i built so then so
then i was a lot freer within those
cases that's really common i hear that a
lot peter yeah a lot of people who who
struggled with um being seen or fitting
in um
they seek refuge and acting i'm
surprised to hear you say it only
because i i guess i had this whole other
image of you in my head um
what was the thing that compelled you to
want to try to act cause for a shy kid i
imagine that that would be a scary thing
to get up in front of other kids and
yeah perform you know it's funny like
when i was little i was like 12 or 13 i
saw butch cassidy and the sundance kid
and i just watched that movie and i
thought wow those guys look like they're
having so much fun yeah like yeah i want
to i want to do that that's what i want
to do i want to play i want to play
cowboys you know like yeah i just want
to do that for a living and then i told
my parents and they kind of laughed at
me because it was like you know telling
them i want to be an actor is like
telling them i want to go to mars you
know
well they were also i didn't know this
they were telling they were from italy
they were first generation yeah yeah i'm
first generation american so they're
actually uh
they're immigrants yeah immigrants wow
both from italy so they they came here
when they were like 18
and then they met they met here so they
they had thick accents they had yeah
they still do they still they still too
wow and did they speak italian in the
house with you did you grow up with that
when i was younger i had three older sis
i still do have three older sisters so
by the time they got to me everybody was
kind of speaking english like
mostly english because they they didn't
you know when they're immigrants they
were like no english is the you know we
want everybody to speak english in the
house and so i wish they did speak
italian more because i wish i knew it
better my my grandmother lived with us
and she was um
she was she only spoke italian so i had
to like get by you know so i could
understand it better than i speak it
what did you call your grandmother did
you have an italian name for her no no
no no i was thinking yeah yeah uh that's
great so and i imagine i mean again i i
don't want to make more assumptions
because i've already made enough about
you but
was it was it because i have italian uh
telling grandmother and
long long as an italian no it's it's so
shortened there's like long and low yeah
it's it was ironically shortened
to long
but it was
my
my grandmother was finale it was that
side of spinelli and
i'm about half italian um but i remember
that side having you know it was like
stereotypical italian meals and eat i
mean my aunt rosie was she literally
said
you know there's constantly pushing like
delicious food on people um was it that
was it like that warm 100
like until a college
maybe senior year in high school i had a
girlfriend who made me those pizza
pockets frozen pizza pockets yes
i thought those were the best things in
the world because i never had one like i
never had like a microwavable dinner i
never had because my mom would cook some
meal but like when you have these you
know luxurious italian meals every night
like the simple like
yeah you know oh my god these are matt
what is this magical
name
and you can cook it in 30 seconds yeah
you know same thing i love that stuff i
think it was like elios or something
really yeah it was and those little
bagel bites i yeah those are those
little bagel bite pizza things but uh
but yeah she cooked every night and
she's an amazing cook and and yeah i'm
blessed
to have have such a great yeah
do you cook yourself did that rub off on
you i mean i do it's uh i get lazy so
postmates is so much easier yes that is
true uh but but i do like to cook i like
when i like to cook for an audience it's
funny because when i have people over
i'm like oh i'd like to cook it you know
i have like i'll do this great meal but
if it's just me i'd be like ding ding
ding hello yeah yeah yeah but now
there's uh well you're having your first
i couldn't help but notice lily you guys
are expecting your first
yeah congratulations thank you so much
really cool what is how does it feel how
are you feeling uh really good i mean i
remember last christmas my daughter's
15 my youngest is 15.
i was getting a little
sad and nostalgic because uh
i remembered like oh when they were
growing up we'd leave plates cookies out
for santa and like salt for the
reindeers and like my dad used to do all
these amazing things like he'd have uh
bricks like pieces of bricks that he'd
leave outside he'd be like santa was too
fat for the chimney looks like there's
pieces of bricks all over my front yard
uh you're related to it yeah
there's a weight problem santa's
morbidly obese
so he wasn't able to bring presents this
year
he ate your presents yeah
so uh
so i was getting sad because i was like
oh i don't i guess i don't get to do
that anymore yeah you know my daughter
my kids are all grown up
so then you know i was talking to lilly
and i can't say and we're like let's do
it again so we get to do it all again oh
that's cool that's cool i get to watch
disney movies again i haven't seen like
like kids disney movies in a long time
because i have a reason to see it i'm
looking forward to i would love to do
that that sounds yeah just just
selfishly just like you see he's in them
you're always voicing them right yeah i
do a lot of those things
yeah i guess so i i sit through some of
those um but now i'll do it with like an
audience that i care about yeah oh you
know you don't have kids you have kids
no no no but i'd love to um
i would love to have that experience i
think it's the
it's the first time i'm really
thinking about it seriously yeah so i'm
in a in a good place but um it must be
strange also to have gone through that
um
and then and and and now you're doing
with somebody who is not familiar with
that who is not yet to go through that
um
so does she feel
does she feel like uh
does she feel a safety in your
experience and your wisdom having done
it
well she's been a great stepmom for
years uh yeah she's she's uh you know
understands what it's like to kind of
parent
of course kids
you know she's been through uh last six
years with my kids who all gone through
like their teenage years oh that's a big
yeah it's pretty it's teenage years
they're tough
they kind of go into their room at 15
and then you know they come out at
dinner sometimes
and then they go right back in their
room and they come out when they really
when they're 18 they come out and then
they're like they're normal again
they're just trying to need some money
like what are they doing in that room i
don't know what they're doing in a room
for three years but do today do you
because you seem like a cool do you seem
young and again maybe i'm just like
imagining you as my
that's like a cool guy but like did they
were they and you and twilight i mean
that must have been a big thing for them
growing up that you were in twilight
uh franchise did they get mileage out of
that did it
did it make you cooler and you're in in
their eyes no because it's like you can
never be cool to your own kids really
like yeah i remember i mean when
twilight first came out my oldest was 15
which was like the
it's like the you know age yes for that
for that movie yeah and uh i feel like i
embarrassed her being in him like i
think she would have liked it more if i
wasn't in it
you're ruining it yeah it's like i
ruined her because like yeah she wanted
to like it but she was like i like harry
potter
all right i like harry potter too
that's funny it's like you got in the
way it's like you threw off the fantasy
like it's kind of like a teen fantasy
yeah and then your dad shows up off the
bubble that's awful amber i gave her a
jacket that gave me this leather jacket
it was like said twilight on the back i
had like the cullen crest there's like
this leather jacket that like any fan
would have been like oh my god that's
amazing i was like do you want this and
she was like dad i'm not gonna be a
poster for your movie i was like
okay
that's funny
and were you tempted to give your kids
uh
the kids that you have were you tempted
to give them italian names italian
sounding names i did kind of like my
oldest one is luca luca bella
which is italian
oh yeah it was just like when you have a
last name like matching ellie it's hard
to be like mary fatchinelli or like you
know bridgette fashionable it's gotta
like
flow
because i know it's so like
sounds like a you know it has a flow
a luca bella fellowship
but luca bella facianelli has to learn
italian it has to speak italian but you
know what i they have their italian
citizenship which is cool like i have my
italian citizenships for my parents so i
i was able to pass it down to them oh
that's cool are any of them interested
in acting do they did they get that
because i i know um you know they have a
lot of that in them yeah my oldest
studied at nyu
which was funny because she went to the
stadium yeah she had some of the same
teachers that i did which is no [ __ ]
a lot of weird it's just really cool um
but she's working in new york now and
she's you know kind of interested in
lots of things and
i never pressure because i'm like with
my family i mean my parents don't really
care what i do it's like
they still don't
like it's not like i could ever impress
my dad because my dad's like you know
john wayne that's that's a great idea
that's an actor yes
i can't work with john wayne because
he's dead
but he's the wife is he's a man
yeah
he doesn't know anybody that was i
called him once i was like really
excited
i said i'm working with uh
i said i said i'm working with drew
barrymore and he and i thought that
would impress him and he goes uh oh is
he nice
that's smart
i was like
forget it did you did you tell her that
story though
oh she would have that that is so
funny
so what did they want you to do i mean
if they had their druthers uh what was
your dad's idea of italian immigrant
imagine it's something to do
what would he want have wanted you to do
ideally
well my dad was a waiter
um
so if you can imagine like the italian
waiter it
uh
which
you know was a profession now it's more
like oh i'm waiting to like do it's a
temporary thing
but but when he came here
you know he was working all the
manhattan like
fine dining restaurants
so
i don't know i mean
my parents never really pushed me in any
direction which which is i'm very
thankful for because i didn't have
overbearing parents
uh
you know like they just kind of let me
do yeah thankfully they
they were so kind of like did not know
much about anything because they were
from italy not that they didn't know
much about anything but they didn't but
that was that's culture i mean
this culture is much so like
like
it sounds sad but like my my parents
never came to any baseball games you
know because they just oh he's going to
baseball you know what i mean
so like i would just go to baseball play
my baseball games come home but they
never
would like you know show up to that
where they wouldn't show up to things
because they just didn't know that like
here's a perfect example
i told my dad i said um you know hey nyu
called me this was like maybe when i was
in my 20s and they want me to give the
speech to the incoming freshman you know
it's really cool that they gave me this
thing it's such an honor that they asked
me to like give a speech to the incoming
freshmen yeah um
and
my mom uh i said my mom goes oh when is
it and i said it's this coming tuesday
you want to come and she goes i gotta do
laundry
that's really funny oh my god i was like
okay
well you should have asked nyu to move
it off the laundry day oh my mom's got
to do laundry today so can we do it
wednesday oh my gosh it is funny but
it's not like she means anything no i
don't know right it's like for her it's
like
she loves me whether i did whatever i
have
so so for me like when i was um
you know i don't i don't want to sound
like it's a bad thing because it because
like my parents didn't even know i was
studying acting until i got a job you
know like mike
but did it ever bother you i mean i know
i you have a very healthy outlook on it
and
you know where it comes from you know
that it's not
ill-intentioned um but did it was there
a time where i was like oh man i would
have liked for them to have
yeah i think there's when i was going i
was like you have the parents that are
like oh my god look what my son made you
know to be here oh yeah you want to put
your artwork on the fridge and it's just
like the biggest piece of junk that
their parents are beaming
i kind of wish i had that that you know
your parents were like what is this
junk yeah what is this junk mom i made
it for school
it's in the other way in the living room
get it out
it's an eyesore my eyes are bleeding my
eyes are bleeding life could be a dream
sweetheart
when you're scrolling through social
media how can you tell what's real
anything can be posted online without
being fact checked but if you heard
about the secret to permanent weight
loss
wouldn't you give it a follow wouldn't
you at least be curious tanya zuckerbrot
founder of the trendy high fiber f
factor diet has celebrity followers
including megan kelly and supermodel
olivia culpo but allegations of
troubling side effects with the diet
began to surface and people started to
question
is she selling powder
or power
emily gelles a popular fashion
influencer christian probably follows
her saw these allegations and put the
diet on blast to her own large social
following she launched a crusade to
expose tanya in the f-factor diet what
was once an online feud escalated into
the real world resulting in threats
lawsuits and a whole
lot of drama from wondery comes a new
series about wealth wellness and
influence listen to fed up on apple
podcasts amazon music spotify or you can
listen early and ad free by joining
laundry plus in the wondery app hey life
is short listeners if you know what this
sentence means it's time to hand out the
roses then you know that the
bachelorette is back man are we happy
about that uh it's been a fun season but
aren't they all with rachel and gabby
two two bachelorettes but did you know
that bachelor happy hour is the one and
only official companion podcast to the
hit reality tv show join bachelor happy
hour co-host becca kufrin and michelle
young every week for exclusive
interviews and episode recaps like you
won't find anywhere else this season
will go down in history for having not
one but two women rachel and gabby set
out on a journey to find love but it's
got us thinking does double the
bachelorettes mean double the drama
i double wonder will gabby and rachel
finally get the happy ending they
deserve who are the men vying for their
roses and will their friendship remain
strong through the end if you're
watching the bachelorette then bachelor
happy hour is a must listen listen to
bachelor happy hour on amazon music
apple podcast or wherever you get your
podcasts or you can listen ad free by
subscribing to wonder plus an apple
podcast under the wandering app
hello
[Music]
did you feel that was can't hardly wait
um
did you know it was going to be iconic
did you know do you have
were the ingredients there was there
do you have any way of knowing that that
would be a movie that lasted and uh
were you nervous doing something like
that were you able to
employ the
tactics that were you were talking about
when you did that movie
i mean
it was one of my first movies it was
interesting when i was you know when i
came out of
when i came out of theater school you
know you get a little bit of air of like
oh well this is too
this or this i want to do more
shakespeare stuff so yeah seriously so i
remember
there was a movie that i was up for it
was this cool little indie
and like you know it was a drama and
some really heartfelt stuff in there and
and uh and then i just finished this
other movie
so this was like my third probably my
third or third movie not like my first
uh like studio movie but you know i
didn't even know the difference really
between an indiana studio at the time i
was just like oh this is working this is
working you know in some ways indie
movies were like cooler to me because
they were like
you know
uh you get to sink your teeth into those
more whereas the studio movies more like
it was also such a vibrant time for
indies i mean it was a time where like
quentin tarantino and
you know kevin smith there were a lot of
like really great hal hartley these
movies being made that were
i i remember even in the in the movie
magazines i remember seeing you in the
movie magazines and like
you know these were the new
up-and-coming guys and and they had done
yeah there was something about indies
that were
it was like kind of cool like i know and
there's like a movie fan just watching
somebody else
yeah
it's like oh
indies you could really sink your teeth
in and student movies are a little bit
more fluffy at the time right yeah so
then can't hardly wait came and i i
remember i went out and read for it
and then and then i ended up getting it
and but it conflicted with this indie so
i almost didn't you can't hardly wait
because i was like you know i want to do
this independent film and you know i
don't want to do this this studio movie
because this india has more grit
and my agents were like you're crazy
like do the studio movie
yeah and then the other movie pushed so
i was actually able to do both what was
the other movie uh it was a movie that
nobody saw so i'm so thankful that like
i actually did this one because i would
have passed on on doing the studio movie
that everybody saw and right and the
other movie when it came and went it was
called like blue ridge falls or
something oh yeah i i kind of remember
that yeah it was amazing
she knows me jay ferguson oh jay
ferguson jr ferguson i don't remember
yeah out of the other cast but it was
really cool these are high school kids
and and one kid is autistic and i'm like
the high school quarterback and i
befriend this autistic kid
and then he ends up uh
killing his dad because his dad was
abusive so he snaps yeah so then my
character feels bad for him so he ends
up like hiding this dad's body because
his dad was like mean you know abusive
drunk spoiler alert now i don't have to
see blue ridge falls yeah
yeah peter were you a football player i
mean you've been you started playing no
i never played football i was i'm too
shy i played i played baseball but like
on a like a church league
but anyway so he ends up like hiding the
dad's body this other guy gets blamed
for it on the team
uh who's black because they're racist in
that town then i have to like come clean
because i don't want that kid to get in
trouble and then i end up going on the
run it's
not really my part no it was a very
gritty cool piece but yeah it was an
indian it kind of came and went yeah
yeah i know i did did a few of those
from like well you didn't see it i
always say like
i preface it by saying you didn't see it
um i loved your scene with with drunk
jerry o'connell friend of the show jerry
best friend of the show jerry jerry yeah
love jerry yes what are some good uh
give me a good jerry anecdote by the way
did were you guys at nyu at the same
time you know i went with his brother i
knew his brother more than jerry but i
knew jerry back then through his brother
charlie charlie yeah and um
who else was in my school skeet all rich
you know skeet oh yeah oh my gosh yeah
skeet was like two or three years
older than me and so he was just like in
a senior where i was a freshman then he
blew up and we were like wow
people can do it wow yeah oh oh they
must have encouraged you guys you know
skeet means something
really uh disgusting that mesquite is
kind of like a naughty word now oh
really i didn't know this some kids came
up to me in michigan with a
camcorder in my face and this was years
ago and they said hey do you skeet and i
said um i thought they were talking
about like
skating
ski i said yeah i skied like skating
they're like no like skeet i said
yeah okay i just wanted them gone yeah i
just wanted to like in the moment so i
said yeah they started giggling and it
come to find out it's um
it's like it's a sec it's uh i think it
means like we should section
it i think it means to ejaculate yeah
i think yeah skeet so i wonder if
mr and mrs ulrich
knew that when they named skee that
anyway i should say that for the skeed
rick episode yeah
but so you knew jerry a little bit when
you did this so i knew him a little bit
um
weirdly him and neil patrick harris oh
yeah sure
taught me a magic trick that with a with
with a fork that i i always use
uh
yeah he was cool even back then what was
the trick um oh it's like a
bending spoon trick and then you go like
that and then it breaks off yeah but i
don't want to tell you how to do it okay
yeah i know he's i'm surprised he told
you how to do it he's very protective of
his magic trick this was way back like
when he first started doing i think
magic because it was like you know it's
been like 1920
yeah um but i haven't seen him in a
while he's doing great um so anyway so
jerry
and
i knew a little bit and then we did
can't hardly wait together and then i've
just you know i've known him through the
years that the last jerry story i have
is
i was at the airport maybe like six
months ago and i was dropping my
daughter off and this is how the funny
universe is because like she's going in
the door and i'm like let me just wait
make sure she doesn't like forget
something you know and as i'm waiting
there to make sure she doesn't come back
i see jerry o'connell walk by yeah like
jerry you bum yeah
i love your work
he got all nervous and then he was like
fetch and i was like yeah i said what
are you doing he's like i just landed i
said hop in i'll give you a ride and i'd
give him a ride home oh no
that's fine
yeah i'll take a ride yeah
yeah
do you
so jerry gets in what do you start
talking about jerry just starts going
right i mean do you it's hard to so what
are you been up to what's going on how
you been how it's going yeah
you look great man
you look good
you look good
but he always means that he doesn't come
out he doesn't know what he's
discontinuing
he's talking about bitcoin back then i
was like buy bitcoin hope you didn't buy
it because it crashed and he's going to
hate me
i gotta ask him yeah yeah peter fetching
only got me into bitcoin and yeah
i lost all my money
did things change radically did you
notice a change in in the world that we
were just walking through the world when
twilight came out like what was that
experience like i mean that was it was
very special because
it was kind of like being part of the
beatles like
everywhere where you went there's like
screams waves of screaming fans you know
what i mean but you knew it wasn't real
like it was like surreal
well you knew it wasn't i mean like you
had i imagine a good foundation for that
in head
you understood the waves of this
business and like the you know but was
there ever a time where you when you
were younger where you didn't quite
understand where you didn't have your
feet as firmly on the ground and like
you were getting hyped or you were
getting you know attention and it felt
did you ever lose yourself
no no if anything it's always been the
opposite like i've never even when i've
been successful i've been like man i
can't wait till i'm like have that one
hit all right
and you're just like
looking at you like what
yeah like i can't hardly wait but you
were in that yeah so uh
so yeah when it first came i was like
i remember going to a
premiere with a friend of mine
and i took my best friend from like when
he was young when we were younger and uh
and he's kind of hispanic he's like
darker skin so i said when you get out
just wait they'll think you're one of
the werewolves you know that's funny
so he got out he started waving and
everybody started screaming
see that and it really thought he was
like he just went like
he just did like uh
they were like literally screaming for
him
and uh wild so that's when you know
like anybody that was playing carlisle
like
anybody that played those roles like
they would have got the same attention
so you're like all right well
you know you go and you give your work
over but you also take it with a grain
of salt
life could be a dream sweetheart
hello hello again
we'll meet again
[Music]
well we have a lightning round if you
don't mind peter i know we gotta go but
this is a quick one what is your
favorite emoji uh what is your go-to
emoji
or what one are you like uh
have you found yourself going to i like
the winky one yep
but i also there's one
it's hard to describe it's kind of a lot
like a full smile but it's like a
you know kind of like a
cute smile with a little yeah with a
little red cheek so it's kind of oh yes
yeah yeah kind of embarrassed smile yeah
is the one do they have the hands up is
it like
no they're not the hands i was just like
yes i know yeah i like that one
it's a little slightly embarrassed it is
um who was your first speaking of
slightly better who was your first
celebrity crush
um well i had two
i think they were like everybody's at my
my age jennifer stewart
well general of you is a staple for sure
um
it was alyssa milano yeah from who's the
boss and then there was uh danica what's
her name danny mckellar mckellar yes
from um
oh
the best danica and her sister i i
always liked her sister who played um
becky slater did you know that they were
sisters no i didn't even know danica's
sister was becky slater who was kind of
like
her character was more of i don't know
if you can say town boy anymore i don't
think he can
if you can let's say just let me get a
pass let me get a boomer pass and say
she was the tomboy on the show um
but yeah danica and i got to work with
danica
uh i was playing like a math genius and
she was playing the like cute
cheerleader next door who was constantly
bouncing on a trampoline
and in real life it was our roles were
not totally reversed because i wasn't a
cute cheerleader but but um i knew
nothing about math and danica was like a
math genius
she's like a math whiz and in fact has a
has a theorem named after her that she
discovered a theorem yeah so she was
crazy right um
so probably not to add to your crush but
she's also very bright um what is your
favorite uh but but eliza milano has
never created a theorem she has no
theorems
what was your uh
what's your favorite ice cream flavor
oh wow um
i like a good chocolate chip cookie
dough yes i mean that's always good
um favorite holiday mention christmas
that's a tough one uh i i think it might
be halloween oh yeah
that's gonna be fun with kids that i'm
looking forward to it's just super fun
to dress again it's like you dress up
i get you know we get to do it all year
round like other people
but for the kids
but like doing it
just dressing up like i get to have a
good halloween party you know you mean
yeah
it's like totally a good theme party
they don't have enough theme parties i
know i know we've been
i know my girlfriend have been talking
about our uh
our what we're going to try to do this
year we have every every couple of weeks
we have a new idea
my dream has always been to have that
like masquerade ball party that would be
like
eyes wide shut but not with like the sex
accents
do you want to know i just write show
party without the sex part yeah it
doesn't seem
just a masquerade yeah
sorry uh what is what is an acclaimed
movie that you're embarrassed to admit
you haven't seen that people are kind of
like maybe shame you for
oh
um
you know
i've seen a lot of movies but you know
what i haven't seen
there's a you know the marilyn monroe
one where her dress goes up
oh yes that's not something like it hot
that's some gentlemen prefer blondes
um well i haven't even seen it either of
that because it's going to be
yeah but i just saw a video about that
the other day i was like you know i've
never seen that movie and i was kind of
embarrassed at myself i don't think it's
like that well i don't think it's one of
her
see now when you look up marilyn
monroe's dress
there you go sage uh miche that's good
call seven year itch i've never seen
either yeah have you seen all the have
you seen all the twilight movies all
four be honest
i'll be unfair
just live yes oh yes all four of them
several times over
uh no i haven't seen it
i haven't seen harry potter i know i
know i saw them all at once i saw them
all but sped up so i watched all four
twilight movies in 20 minutes
um but i haven't seen harry potter i
even see i only recently saw fried green
tomatoes which i don't that's considered
like
one that you should be that people get
shamed for but they should because it's
so good
um anyway this is not a show about me
this is about you what is a game show
pastor present that you would like to be
on a contestant on
um
are they supposed to be speed rounds uh
that's okay
i i think
we will a fortune be fun yeah
uh i just i like to spin that wheel yeah
that would be fun i can't it used to be
a game i'm so afraid i'd always been
afraid when i imagined that i wouldn't
spin it very hard that would just be
like
you know i would give it like a week as
america when i go to vegas there's
always that like the yes
what's that called the crap
yeah no it's uh one of those machines oh
oh really that you spin
yeah no you don't spin it but it has
like a wheel on top
a slot machine yeah a slot machine
doesn't yeah it's limited so i got
covered brand
sloppy shoes
since i've been like since we've been in
quarantine the last couple years like
all of a sudden i'm like what do you
call the thing oh uber
yeah i know it's a thing you dig ice
cream with it it's like a shovel but
smaller oh a spoon
i know so yeah slot machine that has
like the wheel of fortune thing and if
you land on it then all of a sudden it
like spins and i'm always like i gotta
land on that anyway yeah
and i just love pat sajak to me pat
sajak does it better than anybody i am
he is so charming that yeah have you
you know how hard that is to do like to
to be like you know to be at those
whatever if it's a cocktail party or
some hollywood thing to be like
effortlessly without sounding schmoozy
and fake he's so like his small talk
game is
just the best engaging engaging with
people who are like usually like kind of
uncomfortable to be on tv yeah and you
have to kind of go in and out and like
make them feel good and make a little
funny thing out of whatever they've said
it's he's so good i think what was that
do you you're old enough to remember
this game remember the one with the
whammies there's like this little thing
and oh no whammy no whammy no way i mean
yeah they redid that i think i think
press your luck press your life
thanks
yeah um
did you drink coffee peter or tea
uh i i drink tea more of a tea guy but
when i'm
when i'm working on sets like i'll drink
coffee i always have this idea that
it'll like oh this gives me energy but
it doesn't it's it's just like sour
i know you know it's funny i stopped
drinking i was in ireland working and
and so they only drink you know for the
most part it's irish breakfast so i
started drinking to assimilate to get
into the cultures i i drank um irish
breakfast team really got into it and
now i find myself not needing that two
english breakfast tea it's kind of fun
yeah a little punch um if you could
learn another language uh what would it
be would it be italian it would be
italian i mean i know a little italian i
know a little spanish
so like
i'll go down to mexico and i'm speaking
half italian have spanish so i'd like to
know i'd love to be which one's which
yeah i'd like to be fluent in like both
of them that would be really cool yeah
um what is your favorite cereal
um
panda puffs
panda puffs is that like a whole foods
thing yeah
yeah
they're pretty good oh okay um well
there's more of those in your future you
would be able to enjoy them with a
little kid uh if you had to choose a
different first name there's nothing
wrong with peter but if you have to oh
you do yeah because again like peter
doesn't really i never felt like it kind
of flowed with vaccinations
yeah you want to be like mario or yeah
my middle name is um alessandro and i
always thought that's more cool
facianelli would have been very italian
but it's like you know
yeah had a cool flow
alexandra
well you could have gone by that when
you became a professional i could have i
had a hardest time i almost changed my
name a couple of times but i couldn't
like settle on one that i liked so i was
just like well back in the day they also
that was when they wanted you to sound
less
ethnic i mean like they were
de-ethnicizing certain names so
yeah i think my my manager because that
guy mark became my manager yeah
i think he kind of talked me out of it
he was like vaccinated it's a very you
know i was like
and he was like well schwarzenegger you
think that's a tough like people it's
that he made me go he said you know it's
the person who makes the name not the
name that makes the person so that's
like that that's yeah i'm glad
um if you had a sandwich well what name
would you choose peter
alessandro probably i think yeah
if you have a sandwich named after you
the peter fetch nelly sandwich what
would
what would be in the sandwich you'd have
prosciutto
a little um
maybe some parmesan cheese
sounds disgusting but it's actually
pretty good and then you just kind of
like maybe a little crunch crunchy melt
you know press it it's a little yum
yes yeah uh there's of all places i was
in bulgaria i don't know if you've
worked in bulgaria sophia the best
prosciutto panini i've ever had in my
life um i remember going to italy and
like
you go to a gas station and they come
out in these overalls that are like
immaculate and they're like go inside i
take care of your car and they fill your
car with gas they check your oil and
when you're inside they like have these
prosciutto sandwiches wow like really
and you're like ah this is you go to gas
station years like you don't want to
touch anything
but there it's like i was like i love
italy's
prosciutto sandwich while you get gas
yeah oh here you'd be like hey bud do
you have prosciutto sandwiches uh we got
hot pockets and 12 year old hot dogs
wrinkled into um a state of barely being
like
barely being hot dogs at this point um
if you had a uh if if if you were
watching a tom what tom hanks movie
would you most want to see like if you
had a choice of any tom hanks movie uh
wow there's so many great ones um
the one the first one you'll show your
kids i guess the one with the volleyball
comes to mind um
what's that one called
that is castaway castaway i don't know
why that comes to mind but i mean i'm
really excited to watch a great movie
i'm really excited to watch all of this
i haven't seen it yet oh my goodness so
i think that'll be the go to
tom hanks because i'm pretty sure i'm
gonna love that one
um and if you uh are you more of a night
or morning person
uh night
and do you have a routine at night that
you um like a kind of deep down
regulating routine
yeah i do listen to a lot of like uh
hypnotherapy
tapes are like meditative tapes um just
to kind of put me in a relaxed mode and
that usually puts me right out yeah wow
good for you kind of like slows my mind
down yeah yeah
um and do you ever preference the toilet
roll over or under
i mean
probably under but i never really
thought about it okay i mean
probably under because sometimes when
you go over it feels like it
rips more you know i mean like the
gravity feels like if it's under
you'll get more of that spin if you need
but it's not it's never been an issue
you're like you're really
either tugging or you're
pulling
gravity helps i always think over is
just easier access i mean i go under and
then you have to figure out where it's
perforated and yeah
i don't know but but um this is you this
is about you uh
finish if you wouldn't mind peter this
is our last question if you would it's
not even a question it's a request
to finish this sentence
life is short so
enjoy it while it lasts it's great well
i've i have welcome and that's it
i've enjoyed this so much uh
and it is uh it is done that's it you're
you're afraid
you're uh you're you're a cool guy i i
i'm sorry i didn't remember meeting but
oh my god peter no it was so it truly we
were i had opposite i only remember
because i knew you know i knew who you
were and it was kind of like surreal to
me um all right buddy this was so fun
thank you thanks for being here best of
luck to the movies
thank you thank you and the baby thank
you
[Music]
so so that just happened
yeah there's a little bit of like cool
guy cool guy voice i don't know if it's
just
my association with ken hartley with
that i've seen that movie so many times
have you really yes we watch it every
time it's on it's one of those moments i
know i do but i'm sorry well we are
often watching tv together that's true
um i i you know it better you know both
have to watch 10 earlier i'm not like
bragging about it like no i watch it
more
it's uh it's iconic it is it's also like
one of those movies that has
so many people in it that ended up
becoming huge i think that's part of the
stars yeah yeah so it's like oh my god
it's so fun to see a huge star i have
like two lines i know i know little part
you know jason siegel has a really tiny
bit yeah lauren ambrose um seth green i
saw a lot of friends of the show donald
faison i wonder if that movie has the
most friends of the show oh
that's a
oh yeah do you think jerry's listening
oh yeah
why wouldn't he say when he listens
cherry sent us the other day he texted
us a very macabre a very grim story that
happened in a news story that happened
in connecticut and um
he said your neighbors uh so something
what it's you never know what you're
going to get when you open a jerry text
no
no i know it's fun yeah he's got a rate
like a wide range it could be about the
jets preseason it often is it often is
yeah um yeah but that that movie might
i i'm curious now to find out what a
single movie has the most guess oh yeah
that's a good question
who who would do that do you think
there's shorties that are into the show
enough that are shorties and big enough
shorties i don't i don't want to sound
arrogant
but i have a feeling you think i found
that feeling there are that would try to
how would you find also because there
are enough smart people out there who
are good at
technology and there's enough technology
out there that i think would be pretty
easily able
to discover something like that you know
anyway yeah it was uh it's a movie chock
full of friends everyone's so good in it
too i mean we have really good acting
and um that coming of age that time
i love those movies in general coming up
coming of age movies dazing confused oh
yeah oh man yeah i guess you know it is
sort of
the next
type of that movie that that was huge
after days confused wasn't it yeah what
else what were other like semi i mean
it's just about a party i they're very
happy i never realized that
that they're very similar in that way
yeah it's one night one night yeah last
last day of high school yeah yeah it's
very similar and he is great in that
movie um and and so convincing i know
which is why i was very surprised to
learn that he was
shy and not a big jock and not mr
popular because
in that movie he is
completely convincing of that kind of
guy a cocky and like eric i mean just
really like i knew everyone's known
those guys yeah like he
really captured that
you're right it and that's so solidified
in my head as who he is that's happened
before on the show um where i'm i'm
surprised by how i know somebody really
those guys in high school who are like
brilliant at picking up people yeah you
know it's like they've got it down to an
art form yeah and there's like when you
see it now through the lens of like a
wiser more adult lens you recognize
their own hurt you know that they're
like clearly covering up for something
whether it's
whatever struggle that they have and a
little sadism you know the way
peter played it and there was a little
he like took real glee um you know i
remember like some bullying incidents uh
in school where like kids there were
some kids who just like had like they
they got excited about you know if some
kid said the wrong thing or he said
something that like
would set them up to be made fun of like
there were kids who like lit up they
relish
set the chance to like pounce but in
that movie at the end i don't know if
you remember this but he gets very
vulnerable and he cries and he opens up
and he reveals yeah that he does have
these insecurities yeah and then i love
that he gets weaponized he flips it back
and the nerdy character thinks that
they're friends he's like oh hey good to
see you yeah he's like what are you
doing nerd get away from my table
because that was just a moment of
vulnerability he had at a party when he
was drunk totally some people just have
luck yes i can't believe he didn't
remember meeting you
oh well that's flattering i sort of can
he we were all about
no i know but i i know why he doesn't
remember meeting me or or
other people there you know that but he
he you talked to him a lot he did
actually we all talked to him a lot but
he did he had and he didn't even ring a
bell he was like we did
like i i felt i thought he would and
then i felt you know does this ever
happen to you when you're like oh yes we
met at that then you feel immediately
like embarrassed for having remembered
so well when the other course because
you think that the person you're talking
to is imagining you yeah building it up
to this important thing in your life and
it's like you've been thinking about it
well that must happen with i know what
happens uh with with other people with
me because i
it happens with actors it happens with
people that you
already have an awareness of you already
like
he he's always already somebody that i
in a way i know you know having seen
that movie a hundred times
and he was and jenny garth he was
sitting right next to jenny garth who of
course we know from 90210 of course um
kelly taylor
but but you like
overdid it a little bit you were like i
just when i met you it was like surreal
that i was like i know it's like
surreal well
but he was
i know but then you told this story you
told the story about keir thinking he
was a race car driver and he was like oh
yeah
yeah i know he was did not remember at
all i wonder if jenny garth remembers i
i tell you who doesn't remember it for
sure chris notes
yeah there's no way he remembers no he
no north way
he was what what is he yeah tide went on
that night oh he had but i think peter
factionally wanted to be your friend
despite having not remembered you which
then and despite you not having seen any
of the twilight movies yeah he didn't
dizzy was he bothered by that i don't
think so no he's i think he was like
playfully bothered by it he was like to
prepare for this did you see all now he
was funny yeah yeah he had fun with it
and um but then i thought like well oh
that is so nice and it would be nice to
like meet up with him i really enjoyed
talking to him uh it would be funny if
now i like can't get in touch with you
because you're like always busy with
peter fetchinelli
we start doing a podcast together
um let's read a letter okay
i just
you just thought you were in a different
room yeah yeah the old studio
the old studio i like that christian as
is uh part of a chan our heart part of
the champion trophy that we want on the
kevin hart
show um this is a letter from michael
mcgoohy
magui yes how do you spell it
no normal way at michael m-i-c-h-a-e-l
no makui
by the way did i tell you i always have
a hard time spelling michael in all
seriousness i know you've said that um
and then a little c uh that would be
tough for me that's scottish uh m a
little c i thought scottish was m a c
isn't isn't it both is that either one
what is that irish i don't know i should
know this very big
ireland irish file
uh m little c big g
o e y gooey
o u i magoi megoi you know what i i've
resigned myself to never being able to
spell is mcconaughey oh yeah that's
tough do you try it
m c
c o n
a u g h e y and you might be right i
think i am excited holy [ __ ] i think i
forced myself to learn oh really because
yeah i know it knows it's like
laugh i remember thinking like
not he is like l-a-u-g-h m-c okay wait
let me try it m-c
c-o-n-a-u-g-h-e-y
yes holy [ __ ] subject
oh grandma jody conservation
uh would you rather aka
wya i don't know i should read it as he
as he wrote it grandma jody conservation
nola
y-w-r-a-k-a-w-i-r
that's my problem yes and i do and i i
had a hard time just reading it good
morning oh sorry man i i messed up the
second letter of his a second word of
his letter ho boy
good morrow justin christian
is good tomorrow
good tomorrow a good tomorrow good
morning does that mean good day i don't
know
back to michael sorry because there's so
many things i don't know i find myself
saying i agree all the time
isn't that exciting about like it's it's
something that it means you can't hardly
wait to uh oh there's something there
you go and the glass is half full yeah
thank you um back to michael mcgoohy or
magoey sorry or sorry
uh no sorry i just had to hear justin
say that because there's no way to say
it without sounding nerdy
that's funny that's true
good morrow he really does listen he
does he's funny good it's true good
morrow justin and christian it is
it's hard to say cool try to say that
it's cool
like casual yeah yeah
uh good morrow
good morning
good morning good morning picture mike
dexter i know exactly good morrow good
morning tomorrow good morning hey good
morning guys
um i guess it's like i guess that's my
cool voice that's not cool it's like lee
jose slacker
um
anyway please back to michael please
forgive me because there is a lot to
unpack in this email first i would like
to extend my condolences on the passing
of your grandma jody oh it was amazing
to listen to her episode and i thank you
for sharing her stories with us
um that's really nice to hear and not to
um not to be further downcast but uh we
just found out that we lost our other
grandmother uh so shout out to our
uh relatives on that side uh lorraine
long our grandma passed away she was
105. um pretty incredible
and uh a really fun person and um
a good mom good mom yeah so we're
grateful to her for
giving us such a great dad and um
obviously to grandma jody for giving us
the best mom you could ask for so um
thank you for that michael we we think
about her all the time and that's so
nice that other people kind of know her
a little bit now it really makes us
happy uh back to michael i discovered
your podcast recently and heard your
voice memo at the end of the darcy
cardin episode regarding your
grandmother seeing the date of the
episode february 9th 2021 coupled with
your message brought back a flood of
emotions for me as my father passed away
on february 8th wow 2021 i'm sorry to
hear that
uh his passing was the last of a series
in my family over the last two years
we also lost my grandfather grandmother
and my wife's grandmother
but hearing your message about your
grandmother brought a sense of comfort
knowing that we all experience grief and
we are not alone in it
uh yeah i mean i've been thinking a lot
about that recently michael um
secondly i would like to thank you for
both the jeff corwin and jane goodall
episodes hearing jeff and jane each
discuss how dire our environmental
issues are has inspired me to look at my
family's impact to see what we can do
better to recycle or use less that's so
great the two of them should have a
podcast together
yes oh man saving the planet with jeff
and jane the only reason i don't want to
say that is because it would definitely
um be better than our podcast but it
should be it's more valuable for the
world yes yes that was selfish was the
selfish thought i had um back to michael
we have started meatless fridays great
which as catholics wasn't a hard switch
yeah how bad and i also bought my family
a zoo membership so we can better
educate ourselves especially my kids on
conservation and what measures we can
take in our area that's awesome
i also want to thank you and anthony
mackie for your conservation
boy i also want to thank you and anthony
mackey for your conversation about the
city of new orleans my family and i live
just north of new orleans in a suburban
town called slydell
i know slide down me too yeah even
though i visit often i think i was
beginning to take nola for granted but
hearing you two gush over all the people
and places around the city reopened my
eyes to just how magical and special the
city is oh yeah it's the past i miss
that city i haven't been there in so
long you both have to miss new orleans
uh i know man i know we won't go on we
won't labor the point but uh yeah
anthony lives there and obviously is in
love with it lastly i just want to say
thank you for the podcast your brotherly
banter vulnerability and honesty truly
come off as genuine and relatable
listening to your conversations always
brightens up my day that's awesome uh
thank you michael it brightens our day
too so fun to do
uh yes would you rather's would you
rather yes from my seven-year-old
daughter katie katie with a c
cool
uh cool with a k uh these are always my
favorites okay
i'm so excited
would you rather have to always be
barefoot indoors and stub your toe every
time you enter a room
that's good
or fall back in your seat and hit your
head every time you sit
that's
such a good question well
as much as i hate stubbing my toe uh-huh
i
value my head more than my foot
so i would rather stub my toe than hit
my head
you know what i
you know that feeling of hitting your
head when you're not
and it's like you okay so you can't and
you get that like the starry yes it's
terrible it's a terrible feeling and
also eventually you get pretty quickly
you become you'd have damage that's the
real problem yeah
cd right wrong well i guess i'd have to
choose that too even like but stopping
toes every time you wouldn't want to i
would just spend less time indoors or
less time sitting that's what i was
thinking how often do i sit but it's
nice to sit i know i mean we'd have to
be doing this stand you know you do you
would make your helmet if this was a
thing for the rest of your life
you'd have to make your house one
huge room and yeah you're right and and
padded
you know you know nice carpeting shag
cars yeah it wouldn't be that bad one
big open space that's a good question
yeah there's another one would you
rather always have a hair in your mouth
that you can't get out though
that's i just pictured that and that's a
horrible thing
i wouldn't be able to do anything else
in my life no i know when you have a
hair in your mouth you can't concentrate
on you can't think about anything you
can't talk about anything i is this is
tmi
but even during the relationship all
right what's the other thing yeah i know
exactly what you're saying
or
or during the really fun times
or
always have an eyelash in you oh boy
always have an eyelash in your eye that
you can't get out oh the i would rather
have the eyelash you would yeah i would
just because i often don't
you often don't feel that when you have
an eyelash in your eye you you look in
the mirror so sometimes you know when
you see like yeah yeah eyelash on your
eye but i have a real thing about that
i would i would rather have that
than a hair in your mouth yeah there's
something about hair in the mouth is
just but if you knew that it was always
there you you probably get always like
hair hair oh that's a good one i might
do i might get more used to the mouth
one wow because eating and stuff like
what it just never goes away so you you
i think i might get more i also have
this mustache now so i have been getting
little hairs in there which is awful you
have a mustache too i noticed started to
dip into my yeah past my lips did you
not trim you haven't trimmed i'm not yet
no have you yeah i did it the other day
which is gross and it just like reveals
your lips it's in the summer time it's
been hot around here it's especially
awful i can't hardly wait to shave it
okay
um anyway back to michael thank you mike
oh yes mike
mcgoway
joey mcgowey oh i was right mike you
were right mcgowan slidell louisiana ps
i absolutely loved hearing justin find
out the truth about jessica rabbit's
feet so man
yeah i remember that it had me rolling i
could literally hear his mind being
blown also please get jeff goldblum on
the show he is a delight for the senses
and keeps getting better with age i
couldn't agree more and one of these
days i'm going to read my correspondence
i'm just working on my jeff goldblum
impression um
yeah yes i have to work on it i
uh because that my text correspondence
with him about doing the show i've been
trying for like three years yes yeah
every i would say
maybe nine ten months i'll i'll check in
with him and he's never said no he's
never said no
but he punts it in the funniest most
jeff goldblum ways and in the most like
eloquent like
it's almost better than having him on
the show it's just that kind of the
listeners no not just very selfish
anyway mike um what a great what a great
letter thank you and i'm so sorry for
all of the loss that you're contending
with and um wishing you luck on that
journey and uh thanks to katie katie
mcgowey for uh that those great would
you rather's great good one kids always
have kids say the darndest things kids
have the best i know and if you guys
would like to write into the show our
email address is life is short at
wundery.com and thanks to peter
facianelli yes what a guy what a
fascinating guy maybe your future friend
yeah my thatcher friend thank you to
everyone for listening uh we will
talk
to you next week
life is short is hosted by me justin
long it is co-hosted
by um the tagline innovator christian
long he's also a producer another
producer is megan v monaco and katie the
allen senior producer michelle nish lans
audio engineer sergio enriquez executive
producer awesome very handsome marshall
louie
and um and no stranger to podcasts we do
it for a company called laundry
[Music]
so your whole name is reynold
oh
d-o-d-o-o
yeah
wouldn't it be dodu yeah
oh it's dojo yeah
no at least i do do
like americans
call it
oh okay yeah
normally you call it
original is dude oh it's totally okay
and is that uh don't tell me
you're from
where originally i'm going to try to
guess
uh west africa
uh
senegal no no ghana
is it
yeah second guess you got it that's
pretty good yeah
red hole
yeah whoa
tell you yeah
have you been there before no oh okay no
i'd love to go if you like our show
please give us a five star rating and a
review and be sure to tell your friends
the next episode will be out in a week
but you can listen to it right now ad
free by joining wandery plus in the
wondery app you can follow this show on
amazon music apple podcast and the
wondery app or wherever you're listening
right now in the episode notes you'll
find some links and offers from our
sponsors please support them another way
you can show support for the show is by
filling out a survey at wundery.com
survey so thank you for supporting
you